free your body poy doesn't have to be
stiff it can be dynamic expressive and
fun and I want to show you how on March
5th I'm starting a special five-week
session of live stream classes where
I'll teach you how to move with the prop
in ways that you never thought possible
wherever you are in the world you can
join me to learn how to make your PO pop
Glide snap and explode registration is
open now at drexfactor
docomo Dan come join me to dance this
class is available to all levels of Po
Spinners if you can do pendulums
windmills hip reels Buzz saws and caps
you're good to go all classes are
recorded so you can catch up on the ones
you missed or rewatch at your
convenience to learn at your own pace
join a worldwide Ensemble of people
learning to move with their po to tell
stories Express themselves and create
beautiful works of art and if this is
your first time taking class with me you
can get 20% off the price of the course
when you use the code first time at
checkout again you can sign up over at
drexfactor comom
slive Dan and I hope I get to see you in
class